menteur non je m'en passe te jure que je
peux enfin en tête 12 mois un tout petit
peu mais je suis producteur c'est mon
boulot et je te rembourserai je te
promets que je te rembourserai je te
donne 72 heures après ça j'étais trop
[Musique]
content pour un coût je crois que t'as
pas dresser un portrait tout à fait
juste de notre investisseur à va à
chaque fois qu'on l'a été dans la mer
drom on m'a trouvé les solutions tout le
monde ne parle que de ça il faut du fric
vous avez qu à venir sur le plateau
franck pierce sera là excusez moi
monsieur pierce pardon vous interromps
je peur
ils étaient assurés à hauteur de 5
millions de dollars en soirée deux tons
pâles seul plan du film et ils empochent
5 millions de dollars vraiment aurait
vécu tout ce qui serait resté ses
indemnités de la science
j'ai organisé une entourloupe commence à
une anthologie on prépare tout comme si
on l'avait vraiment l'intention de faire
un film qui on prend une grosse
assurance pour la star qui fera ses
casques et autres vous êtes ue que
montano ici tueur montana qu'est ce que
vous faites du coup mentalement petite
séance de roulette russe quotidienne
vous êtes parfait pour ce personnage en
particulier je me suis tout de suite
attaché à cette histoire rona et c'est
un bon vieux western à l'ancienne un
kingdom quoi
félicitations
par occupant dans une cascade il rêve et
là on est riche on est riche
zoomons fama s'il était encore en vie je
sais très bien qu'il doit aider les onze
buts un de canassons zouk mais c'est
génial vous êtes vivant tu venais pas ce
cas là on dirait qu'il a deux filles ça
n'a rien de sorcier de tuer quelqu'un
dont on va tourner et l'incroyable scène
du pont de corde qui en a qui vont pas
en revenir sans votre ses pieds sauter
avec mes bottes pourrait-il
je te collerais autre oeuvre toute
équipe donnerait sa vie pour tous et pas
les mots que j'aurai choisi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais enfin quelles sortes d'êtres
humains est ce que tu es je suis
producteur
pour réaliser un film à un million de
dollars et vont rouler dans super tie &
suis pas adepte des signes ostentatoires
d'opulence êtes con qua non